what if I told you your day your week
your month your your your life your
career is a reflection of the lens you
put on this morning when you woke up
what if I told you that and I'm not
talking about glasses I'm talking about
a lens lemak spent - what I mean by this
last week at a conversation one of my
employees I brought I ran it was a
goal-setting type of a situation that
her and I were having and I was
challenging her I said listen who do you
want to be what he want to do with your
life and I said why are you not giving
your all to be in your best what is it
and going back and forth all of a sudden
she breaks and she sits there and she
says you know what I got to take this
story that's really stuck with me all
these years I said what is it she says
years ago I had a lady that was my
mentor she was a fortune 100 CEO she had
the house the cars the money the records
the the accolades the books all of it
she was amazing at what she did except
while I was by her deathbed she started
opening up to me and she told me listen
my husband left me my kids I want to
talk to me I don't have great
friendships whenever it comes down to
you giving everything you got to your
career and your goals and dreams step
back a little bit because it could come
at a cost of your husband your kids your
family I wouldn't do that if I were you
that's stuck with her from that moment
and so she says Pat why would I give
everything I got why would I want to
give my best look how many people are
dying what are they taking with them
they don't get to take the cars the
money the houses they don't get to take
all that stuff why should I give
everything I get to enjoy my life a
little bit more I see you know it's so
interesting you say that you're not
alone there there's millions of people
that hesitate I've given their best
because of the lens they put on every
morning I said I want you to think about
something let's just say you're thinking
about getting married she said okay
I said I take you and we do focus Cora
market research together with you I take
you into a room with ten couples that at
one point were married to each other and
they made millions because they went for
their careers and they decided to get
married and have kids
ten couples when you walk into the room
you look at these ten couples then I
asked the ten couples to reveal how it
turned out for them five of them stand
up and this five that stands up their
marriage didn't work out they can't
stand each other they're not friends
they have okay relationship with their
kids and they lost it all with their
careers and they got a regular life
five out of the ten three of them lived
in okay life was a good life they've
been traveling they're doing okay but it
wasn't great relationship so it was good
relationships it was in a great life it
was a good life
it wasn't great experience it was good
experiences and into at the end lived an
incredible life I'm talking incredible
legacy type of a life good relationship
with their kids they're proud of their
kids they're proud of their family not
saying they don't have problems of
course they argue their father had some
issues with finances their kids made
some mistakes but they ended up having a
great life because of the lens they put
on I said here's a question for you she
said what's that I said if you walked
into that room and you got these ten
couples to choose from and you're
thinking about marriage and you walk out
saying oh my gosh did you notice half of
them got a divorce and the marriage
didn't work out and they can't stand it
did you notice how ticked off he was
when he talked about her and that one
couple out I never want to do that I
don't ever want to give my best to curry
or married you can tell it doesn't work
out that's a reflection of the lens you
look at the world from but if you walked
in and you said oh my kid did you see
the two people the life they left do you
see what their kids did man what if that
happened to my life what if I was able
to do what they did what if I was able
to build somebody a family like that
what if I was able to have a marriage
like that that's crazy
whatever you look at when you leave
dictates how you view the world and
that's a byproduct of the lens you put
on this morning by the way the lens
isn't just marriage and money spiritual
health finance relationship friendship
have politics everything has to do with
the lens you put on so now you may ask
the question what Pat how do I change
that lens it's not easy by the way but
how do I change it okay what is it a
byproduct of your lens is a byproduct of
what you let in whether it's your family
friends shows books audio co-workers
peers what you let in without filtering
it you have to filter and not let things
there like you have to when somebody's
feeding you something you have to say
I'm not accepting this mindset I'm not
I'm sorry I don't buy into this concept
or else it's gonna go in and if it goes
in you believe it then it shows here
here's a second part so one is what you
let it the second part is this what you
let out it's a leak to the
world of your fears and concerns it's a
leak of your insecurities it's a leak of
your hazard if you leak out all the
fears all the concerns all the worries
that's what you attract if you
constantly leak it this is not about not
being a you know vulnerable not at all
I'm talking about everything comes out
is a little bit entitled there's a
little bit victim it's a little bit
while you don't understand but my life
and the way I was raising all of that
also tracks the life so for you if
you're watching us here and you maybe
relate to her because I think at some
point everybody does you got to kind of
grab a paper and pen and write down how
you view the world in every aspect of
life you have to write it with marriage
finance money business health exercise
politics everything figure out exactly
how you view the world and then ask
yourself is this producing the life that
I want and then start scratching some of
them off scratch them off
and then go find people where you want
their life and ask them how do you view
the world and start buying some of them
and put it in here and then let it come
out and I see what happens to your life
but if you don't change the lens life
ain't gonna get better so starting today
my challenge to you do that one exercise
and then after that put on the right
lens and see what happens to the rest
your life
you
[Music]